Rick Fernandez is asking what does
Brandon think of the recent running
photos of Nick Diaz and Derek Lewis for
black beast he's he's really gotten down
man he's taking his condition another
level which is good for him he looked
phenomenal just he resigned with UFC so
there's a Resurgence there he's trying
to take it more serious because he was
kind of on The Cutting Board there uh
for Nick Diaz I think he is getting in
shape for a comeback against a Jake Paul
or Logan Paul yeah that would make this
the biggest fight you can make the most
money
also the easiest fight from as far as
him jumping back into the UFC tough task
for him but those those big Marquee
fights that you make a ton of money ton
of exposure I could see Jake Paul Nick
Diaz next